Ahoj, jmenuji se Olivia Lan a jsem výzkumnice a pedagožka v IBM Quantum. Toto video zahajuje
zcela novou sérii na YouTube kanálu Qiskit a na naší vzdělávací platformě s názvem Quantum Computing v
praxi. Stručně řečeno, v této sérii ti ukážu, jak naplno využít kvantový počítač, který existuje právě teď.
Na internetu jsou již miliardy videí o kvantových počítačích, jejich budoucím potenciálu nebo o teoretických konceptech
kvantové výpočetní techniky, které jsou stejně tak důležité – viz kurz Porozumění kvantové informaci a výpočtům,
který hostuje John Watrous – ale v tomto kurzu budeme předpokládat, že posluchač možná ví o trochu více
než dřív, a půjdeme velmi daleko z technického hlediska. A to proto, že za poslední rok, a
v době tohoto záznamu je rok 2024, jsme viděli posun – fázový přechod, chcete-li – do nové éry
výpočetní techniky. Kvantové počítače se konečně blíží bodu, kde mohou být užitečné. Přestože experimentování s
malými circuit a kvantovými počítači bylo nezbytné pro vzdělávání naší komunity v tom, jak tyto stroje využívat, nikdo nespouštěl experimenty,
které by nešlo provést i na běžných klasických počítačích. Ale od dnešního dne jsme vstoupili do éry
kvantové užitečnosti. A co je to užitečnost, ptáš se? Liší se od kvantové výhody, kterou lze chápat jako
bod, ve kterém kvantové počítače překonávají klasické počítače ve smysluplném úkolu. Užitečnost naproti tomu znamená,
že spolu mohou začít soupeřit, a to je přirozený další krok v technologickém
vývoji. IBM zveřejnilo studii, která ukázala, že poprvé loni byl kvantový počítač použit k
simulaci fyzikálního modelu a konkuroval nejmodernějším klasickým simulačním technikám. Dokonce překonal
metody hrubé síly a výzkumníkům otevřel novou cestu pro výzkum. Proč se to všechno děje
právě teď? V posledních několika měsících IBM zpřístupnilo kvantové procesory s více než 100 qubit široké veřejnosti. Pokud jsi
již uživatel, možná sis všiml, že jsme odstranili mnoho našich menších procesorů, abychom uvolnili místo těmto větším čipům, a cítili jsme, že to bylo opravdu
důležité udělat, protože určitý počet qubit lze stále klasicky simulovat bez problémů – takže
z jejich používání nelze získat žádnou skutečnou výhodu. Nicméně při 100 qubitech to již neplatí – nelze je
klasicky simulovat. Důležité je také zmínit, že existují takzvané simulátory,
což jsou v podstatě počítačové programy, které dokáží napodobit některé chování kvantových systémů včetně šumu. Prosím tě ale,
nevynech fakt, že jsem řekla „napodobit" – simulátory nejsou kvantové počítače, nemohou produkovat výsledky, které
kvantové počítače v tomto měřítku mohou. Jsou však stále důležitou součástí našeho testovacího workflow. To byla tedy velmi
obsáhlá odpověď na otázku z nadpisu tohoto snímku: Co je praktické kvantové výpočetnictví? V tomto kurzu tě naučím o realistických
potenciálních případech použití pro kvantové technologie a o nejlepších postupech pro spouštění a experimentování na těchto rozsáhlejších
procesorech dnes. Takže na koho je tento kurz zaměřen? Začněme nastavením základní úrovně.
Na začátku: tento kurz je pro každého, kdo chce vyvíjet nové aplikace pro kvantové počítače,
chce vědět, jak rozšířit svou stávající práci, nebo se naučit, jak kvantové technologie použít ve svých stávajících workflow. Jak jsem předtím
zmínila, tento kurz bude velmi praktický a teoretickými aspekty se nebudeme zabývat zdaleka tak moc.
Očekáváme, že přijdeš se základním chápáním toho, co je kvantová výpočetní technika, ale pokud tam ještě nejsi, nevadí – stačí se podívat
na první pár epizod kurzu Johna Watrousa a budeš připraven. Také chceme zajistit, aby diváci věděli,
že to není jen kurz pro fyziky nebo dokonce informatiky – tyto dva obory si kvantové výpočetnictví
monopolizovaly poslední desetiletí. Chceme zajistit, aby i ostatní, kdo pracují s velkými daty nebo
simulacemi – například inženýři, chemici a materiáloví vědci – věděli, že tento kurz je i pro ně. Stručně řečeno, tento
kurz je určen širokému publiku a doufáme, že se k nám připojíš po celou dobu. Po absolvování tohoto kurzu
budeš rozumět tomu, jak vytvořit a spustit úlohu v měřítku utility přes Qiskit runtime, včetně celého workflow.
Budeš schopen porozumět hlavním typům zmírňování chyb a také pochopit pravděpodobné oblasti aplikací v krátkodobém horizontu. Budeš také schopen
provádět všechny tyto algoritmy v Qiskit a nakonec očekáváme, že budeš schopen porozumět šumu a tomu, jak s ním pracovat.
Tak pojďme na to. Kvantová výpočetní technika je vzrušující nová technologie v rané fázi vývoje, ale je to jen
jedna kapitola v příběhu výpočetní techniky, který sahá tisíce let zpět. Myslím, že je důležité tomuto
kontextu rozumět, protože to, o co se zde snažíme, dělá trochu intuitivnějším, předvídatelnějším a méně
sci-fi. Od starověku jsme jako lidé potřebovali provádět výpočty neboli
zpracovávat informace podle určitých pravidel a omezení, abychom umožnili
komunikaci, výstavbu, obchod, vědu a všechny ostatní aspekty našich životů. Hledali jsme pomoc ve fyzickém světě
a prostřednictvím geniálních objevů jsme zkonstruovali zařízení, která nám pomáhají počítat. Dávno zařízení byla
vyrobena ze dřeva, kostí, uzlovaných provazů a ukládala informace a usnadňovala výpočty velmi odlišně od toho, jak to děláme
dnes. Mechanická zařízení postavená z pák, ozubených kol a jiných strojů se vyvinula od raných astronomických hodin přes
kalkulačky až po sofistikované výpočetní přístroje, jako jsou diferenciální analyzátory, které řešily rovnice pomocí kol a
rotujících disků. Dokonce i technologie písma sehrála důležitou roli v tomto příběhu tím, že lidem umožnila provádět
výpočty, které by jinak nedokázali. Když dnes přemýšlíme o počítačích, máme tendenci přemýšlet o
elektronických digitálních počítačích, ale to je ve skutečnosti poměrně nedávná technologie. Elektronické digitální počítače
byly poprvé postaveny ve 40. letech 20. století. Nejstarší známý nástroj pro výpočty je sumerský abakus,
který odborníci považují za vynalezený v Babylonu kolem roku 2700–2300 př. n. l. To je opravdu
hodně dávno. Ale my jsme stále lépe pochopili přirozený svět – od Archimeda přes Euklida až po
Einsteina – a naše potřeba více výpočetních zdrojů raketově vzrostla. Dnes máme superpočítače, což jsou
v podstatě mnohé velmi výkonné počítače zapojené paralelně. Jsou jedním z nejlepších nástrojů, které lidstvo má pro
řešení obtížných problémů, ale stále existuje spousta problémů, které ani tyto obří počítače nikdy nebudou schopny
vyřešit – o tom více později. Takže jsme zjistili, že lidé využívají fyziku a přírodu, aby jim pomáhaly počítat
tisíce let, a pro pomoc s naším nekonečným úsilím počítat více a větší věci možná již
WEBVTT
znáš Moorův zákon. Ve skutečnosti to zákon úplně není – je to spíše pozorování, ta část se zákonem je podle mě trochu
s nadsázkou. Maximální počet tranzistorů v integrovaném obvodu – v podstatě v počítačovém čipu –
se přibližně každé 2 roky zdvojnásobuje. Během posledních pěti desetiletí jsme to nejen pozorovali, ale také toho skvěle využili.
S více tranzistory lze provádět více a rychlejší výpočty. To je v podstatě to, co stojí za
tím, že počítače jsou stále výkonnější a menší. S časem však přichází špatná zpráva – Moorův zákon umírá.
Odborníci se neshodují na tom, kdy Moorův zákon dospěje ke svému nevyhnutelnému konci, ale někteří říkají, že již nastal. Přestože možná nejsme
přesně jisti, kdy dosáhneme svého limitu, víme, že je to nakonec nevyhnutelné, protože některé části tranzistorů
nelze fyzicky zmenšit. Nelze například vytvořit tranzistor menší než atom –
to je samozřejmě zcela nefyzikální, zní to hloupě, ale to jsou limity, se kterými skutečně pracujeme. Co tedy
uděláme? Prostě se vzdáme a řekneme: „Hej, to je to nejlepší, čeho můžeme dosáhnout"? Ne, lidé to nikdy neudělali. Naštěstí do
konverzace vstoupila kvantová mechanika. Kvantová mechanika byla objevena ve 20. letech 20. století a od té doby
svět doslova nikdy nebyl stejný. Mohli bychom strávit hodiny hovorem o revolučních objevech, které byly
učiněny, ale to opravdu není zaměření tohoto kurzu. Místo toho chci jasně říct, že víme, že kvantová
mechanika a výpočetní technika jsou již spolu navzájem kompatibilní. Poznatky a pochopení přírody,
které jsme získali z kvantové mechaniky, částečně umožnily naše moderní počítače. Bez kvantové
mechaniky bychom pravděpodobně ani nerozuměli, ani nebyli schopni vynalést pevný disk na bázi polovodičů
například. Kvantová výpočetní technika je jednoduše přirozeným dalším krokem v tomto vývoji.
Ale výpočetní technika neexistuje ve vakuu – informace vyžadují médium.
Výpočetní informace využívají fyzický svět a také ho ovlivňují. To klade omezení na to, co je vůbec
fyzicky možné, ale porozumění přírodě a fyzickým omezením je vlastně cílem fyziky jako
disciplíny. Takže svým způsobem fyzika a výpočetní technika byly vždy propojeny. Ralph Landauer, informatik a
IBMák, si před desetiletími uvědomil, že informace jsou fyzické. Jinak řečeno, informace nejsou
abstraktní entitou, ale existují pouze prostřednictvím fyzické reprezentace. Landauerův princip navazuje spojení
mezi informacemi a zákony termodynamiky. Ve skutečnosti ale existuje mnoho spojení mezi fyzikou a
výpočetní technikou. Klasická fyzika byla vše, co jsme mohli zkoumat až donedávna, ale s objevem kvantové
mechaniky jsme nyní na prahu schopnosti vytvořit zcela nový způsob výpočtu. A to je skvělé, protože
klasické počítače mohou pouze aproximovat to, co se skutečně vyskytuje v přírodě, a v některých případech je tato aproximace velmi
omezená. To proto, že je opravdu, opravdu těžké přimět stroje, které se řídí zákony klasické fyziky, aby
aproximovaly zákony kvantové fyziky – a příroda není klasická, je kvantová. Jedna analogie, která ti může pomoci
pochopit, je větrný tunel. Dynamika tekutin je notoricky obtížná na simulaci a matematické předpovědi.
Dokonce něco tak banálního jako auto jedoucí skrz vítr – výrobci automobilů zjistili, že bylo skutečně
příliš nákladné a nepraktické pokoušet se simulovat tuto fyzickou interakci při navrhování aut. Místo toho co
udělali, vytvořili doslova tunel, který jím fouká vítr, a auto do tunelu jednoduše zajedou,
aby viděli, jak se chová. To je analogické k tomu, co mám na mysli, když říkám, že klasické počítače přírodu
špatně aproximují a někdy je příliš nákladné to vůbec zkusit. Místo simulace větru
ho výzkumníci jednoduše znovu vytvoří. Stejně tak kvantové počítače nemusí aproximovat zákony přírody na
molekulární úrovni, protože se těmito zákony řídí ze své podstaty. Nemusí nic simulovat – emulují to, a
stejné obtíže nastávají při simulaci baterií nebo chemických reakcí, což nás přivádí k naší další
části: Kvantová výpočetní technika – k čemu je dobrá?
Proč bychom vůbec chtěli uvažovat o kombinování kvantové mechaniky a výpočetní techniky? No, existují již dost
problémů, které jsou příliš obtížné, příliš výpočetně nákladné i pro naše nejmodernější superpočítače.
Možná jsou to problémy, na které se soustředí pouze výzkumníci, ale jejich dopady by mohly zasáhnout všechny části
zeměkoule. Tyto problémy, na kterých klasické počítače uvíznou, jsou věci, na které se jako společnost stále více
spoléháme v technologiích a skutečně nám záleží – jako efektivita baterií, finanční modelování a
optimalizace a dokonce jak stavět lepší letadla. Proč se tedy obrátit na kvantové počítače? Máme velmi dobré důvody
k domněnce, že tu je velký potenciál, a můžeme otevřít dveře k novým výpočtům, které jsou v současnosti nedostupné dokonce i
pro nejsilnější superpočítače. Teoreticky některé kvantové algoritmy poskytují výhody oproti
nejlepším možným klasickým algoritmům pro některé aplikace. Pro jiné aplikace existují narůstající důkazy, že dokonce
i s určitým šumem a nedokonalostmi mohou být kvantové počítače stále použity jako nástroj ke konkurenci klasickým metodám hrubé
síly. V podstatě je to zcela nový nástroj a chceme přijít na ještě více skvělých věcí, které s ním můžeme dělat. Ale můžeme se
také ohlédnout za Feynmanovou původní myšlenkou – použít je k pochopení fyziky a přírody samotné.
Příroda je ostatně, jak jsem již říkala, kvantová, nikoli klasická. A tato oblast je neuvěřitelně bohatá, fascinující a
interdisciplinární – spojuje fyziku, informatiku, zpracování informací a samozřejmě konkrétní oblasti aplikací, o které
bychom mohli mít zájem. Narozdíl od klasických počítačů však ne každý má kvantový počítač schovaný v kapse.
Donedávna, pokud jsi chtěl experimentovat s kvantovým počítačem, musel sis ho sám postavit a udržovat –
obvykle v neutěšené laboratoři v suterénu univerzity nebo výzkumného zařízení, a věř mi, já bych to věděla. To již
ale neplatí. V roce 2016 IBM umístilo první kvantový procesor do cloudu. Tehdy měl jen pět qubitů a
poměrně vysokou míru chyb, ale to bylo jen před 8 lety – a podívej, jak daleko jsme se dostali. Kde tedy dnes stojíme?
Je hodně paralel s úplnými začátky moderního počítače. Jak jsem zmínila, je to velmi
těžký úkol a teprve za posledních 8 let se kvantové počítače staly široce dostupnými – krom
těch, kdo pracují v špičkové laboratoři nebo zařízení. Ale za těch posledních osm let jsme dosáhli pokroku na každé
WEBVTT
frontě – procesory jsou řádově větší co do počtu qubitů, gate jsou výrazně vylepšeny a zavedli jsme metody
pro snižování nebo zmírňování chyb vlastních kvantovým systémům, i zatímco tlačíme vpřed na vytvoření odolných
kvantových počítačů. Nyní ty a kdokoli jiný můžete využívat jeden z těchto mnoha IBM Quantum procesorů,
hostovaných v cloudu – skoro všechny jsou nejnovější a nejlepší systémy s více než 100
qubitů. Ale důležitá není jen velikost procesorů – to je pouze jedna metrika, která nás zajímá, a
to dává smysl, ne? Pokud máme více qubitů, je to samozřejmě lepší, za předpokladu, že zvýšení počtu qubitů
nesnižuje výkon. To ale není vždy pravda. Potřebujeme více kvalitních qubitů, které se navzájem neovlivňují
přes přeslech, když to nechceme. Důležité je také mít na paměti, jak jsou qubitů vzájemně propojeny. V
supravodivých circuit je výzvou přijít na to, jak qubitů fyzicky nejlépe propojit. Další velmi důležitou metrikou
je věrnost dvoiqubitového gate. Gate fungující na jednotlivých qubitech nejsou tak náchylné k chybám – dvoiqubitové gate jsou mnohem
větší oblastí zájmu a obvykle jednou z hlavních metrik, které sledujeme, abychom viděli, jak se výkon zlepšuje
v průběhu času. Dvoiqubitové gate je zásadní správně nastavit, protože jsou zodpovědné za vytváření provázání mezi qubity,
což je jeden z fyzikálních jevů, které dávají kvantovým počítačům jejich sílu. Nakonec hledáme rychlost a efektivitu –
musíme zajistit, aby čas strávený spouštěním programu na kvantovém čipu byl proveden co nejrychleji a co nejefektivněji.
Tato tři měřítka označujeme společně jako škálování, kvalitu a
rychlost – všechna jsou nezbytná pro zlepšení výkonu. Teď ti chci ukázat pár rychlých grafů na podporu toho, co jsem říkala
o tom, jak se technologie sama o sobě skutečně rychle vyvíjí. Počet qubitů je asi nejsnazší k
pochopení a IBM zveřejnilo plán, kde doufáme být v příštích pár letech z hlediska počtu qubitů
a velikosti procesoru. Pro rok 2024, kdy toto video natáčíme, jsme přesně v souladu s naším procesorem Heron a Condor. Dál:
kvalita – tento graf ukazuje medián míry chyb provazujícího gate pro procesory IBM Quantum v průběhu času. Mějte na
paměti, že jde o logaritmické měřítko, takže ačkoli pokrok vypadá přibližně lineárně, ve skutečnosti je mnohem rychlejší, než se zdá.
A nakonec rychlost – tento graf ukazuje pokrok metriky, které říkáme CLOPS, což znamená circuit layer
operations per second. CLOPS v zásadě zahrnuje jak čas potřebný ke spuštění circuit, tak potřebné reálné a
blízkoreálné klasické výpočty. CLOPS je v podstatě měřítko toho, jak rychle naše procesory mohou spouštět konkrétní circuit
za sebou – slouží jako měřítko celkové rychlosti systému a zahrnuje kvantové i klasické
výpočty. V době záznamu je IBM jediným poskytovatelem kvantového cloudu, který poskytuje přístup ke strojům s 100
a více qubitů. Jak jsem zmínila před pár snímky, 100 qubitů nebo tak – to je místo, kde klasická simulace
začíná zcela selhávat. Takže rozsáhlé úlohy spouštěné na těchto strojích often nemají žádný klasický ekvivalent – jednoduše to
není možné. Existuje určitá nuance a triky, jak simulovat některé části circuit a poté jiné části
odděleně, ale obecně víme, že právě kolem tohoto čísla mohou kvantové počítače začít dělat věci, které klasické počítače prostě nedokážou.
IBM se tedy rozhodlo, že zpřístupnění těchto větších zařízení je pro širší komunitu velmi důležité, protože cokoli
prováděné na menších zařízeních je klasicky simulovatelné, a proto nemůže vést ke kvantové výhodě. Zařízení se 100 qubitů,
která máme nyní, jsou stále nedokonalá a hlučná, takže musíme být chytří v tom, jak spouštíme úlohy a
circuit na nich. Naivní přístup – prostě napsat circuit a stisknout Shift+Enter – nás pravděpodobně k ničemu
spektakulárnímu nepřivede. Ale opět existují tipy a triky, které můžeme implementovat, a osvědčené postupy, které můžeme dodržovat, abychom vytěžili ještě
více výkonu z těchto zařízení, což doufejme povede ke kvantové výhodě dříve, i zatímco pokračujeme
v práci a budování našich odolných strojů. Tento graf ukazuje náklady na simulaci,
neboli dobu potřebnou k vyřešení problému na klasických počítačích a kvantových počítačích vybavených zmírňováním chyb
a korekcí chyb. Klasická výpočetní linie tedy roste exponenciálně se složitostí circuit.
Pro jednoduchá circuit tady dole to nevadí, ale je to samozřejmě špatné, jak složitost roste, protože to
zvyšuje náklady na simulaci velmi rychle. Zmírňování chyb se škáluje lépe, takže když složitost circuit
roste, zde chceme být. Momentálně jsme tady – klasické a kvantové metody jsou přibližně
na stejné úrovni pro některé aplikace, a korekce chyb by mohla být nejpreferovanější a škáluje se opravdu
dobře – jen tam ještě nejsme. Mezitím budeme nadále zaměřeni na zmírňování chyb a na co nejrychlejší dosažení
oblasti kvantové užitečnosti. Využitím několika schémat zmírňování chyb, o kterých se
v této sérii naučíme, chceme najít oblasti aplikací, které mohou kvantovou užitečnost brzy využít. A to je
skutečné srdce tohoto kurzu – máme tyto stroje, myslíme, že jsou schopné provést nějaký velmi zajímavý
výzkum, tak jak je používat? V této poslední části epizody si stručně probereme oblasti aplikací pro
praktické kvantové výpočetnictví. Existují tři hlavní větve, které nás nejvíce zajímají a kde hledáme cesty pro kvantovou
užitečnost. První je simulace přírody – to má co do činění se simulací molekulárních nebo atomárních interakcí a je
to skutečně důležité pro oblasti materiálových věd a chemie. A z důvodů, o kterých jsme hovořili dříve, si myslíme, že kvantové
počítače budou v tomto mnohem lepší než jejich klasické protějšky. Dál je hledání a
optimalizace – hlavní algoritmus zájmu se nazývá QAOA, hybridní klasicko-kvantový algoritmus. QAOA používá
klasický počítač k trénování a nalézání optimálních parametrů pro kvantový circuit a doufáme, že to bude možné dělat
mnohem efektivněji, než by mohl každý počítač zvlášť. Nakonec máme matematiku a zpracování dat se strukturou – kvantové
počítače jsou opravdu dobré v nalézání struktury v chaotických datech, kde ty, já nebo typický počítač nemusíme
nic vidět. Kvantové strojové učení slibuje v této oblasti a chceme ho využít pro úkoly jako extrakce příznaků
a rozpoznávání vzorů. Je to skutečně velmi vzrušující doba pro ty z nás, kteří pracují v
oblasti kvantové výpočetní techniky. Poprvé v historii můžeme začít zkoumat oblast výpočetní techniky, která leží za hranicemi
klasické výpočetní techniky. Ti z vás, kteří toto sledují, by mohli sehrát roli podobnou raným průkopníkům
výpočetní techniky, kteří neměli ponětí o tom, co bude následovat. T. J. Watson z IBM dokonce slavně prohlásil, že si myslel,
WEBVTT
že trh existuje jen pro dva nebo tři počítače celkem – a jak se mýlil. My
jsme všichni těmi ranými průkopníky výpočetní techniky, ale v tomto novém oboru kvantové výpočetní techniky. Kvantová je často
stavěna do kontrastu s klasickou výpočetní technikou jako něco zásadně odlišného a často v konkurenci s ní, ale
mým cílem pro tuto úvodní přednášku bylo doufám tě přesvědčit, že z pohledu orla vidíme kvantovou
výpočetní techniku jako jednoduše další kapitolu v dlouhém příběhu výpočetní techniky. Je naší přirozeností jako lidí hledat nové způsoby,
jak počítat, využívat sílu přirozeného světa a přijít na to, co s tím dělat – a děláme to
po staletí. Kvantová výpočetní technika nám nabízí nový nástroj v tomto úsilí a je na nás, abychom zjistili, jak můžeme využít
sílu, kterou nám nabízí. V příští lekci série si trochu více popovídáme o systémech se 100 qubitů
a podáme přehled o Qiskit, našem softwarovém SDK pro kvantové výpočty, a o tom, jak s těmito stroji nejlépe interagovat právě teď. Díky za
sledování a uvidíme se příště.